storytelling is incredibly important for
entrepreneurs and more important than
ever before because every business
startup has to be able to tell their
story in social media in ways that they
have never been required to do I mean it
used to be that businesses started up
and they would do ads in magazines or
newspapers or 30-second commercials on
TV and there was really little time for
storytelling but today you have the
opportunity through social media to you
know do a video or do you know tell your
story at length and communication in
business in general is more important
than ever
be authentic authenticity is more
important than ever if you are not
authentic you are going to be exposed
because it is so easy for people today
to find out the truth and we're seeing
that more and more in you know companies
people business people who are not you
know who are inconsistent in their
message so you have to be authentic you
have to be consistent in your message
and you have to be able to tell tell it
in a narrative way I mean I'm a
journalist and to me the best stories
are about people who have a vision have
a dream aspire to it achieve fail learn
and achieve again and everybody's who's
successful today fails at a point and
learns from it and becomes a better
person and to me as a journalist if
that's not part of the story I'm not
that interested